since we started from the first
immediate unity and return through the
moments of formation and of process to
the unity of both these moments and thus
back again to the original simple
substance this reflected unity is
different from the first contrasted with
that immediate unity or that unity
expressed as a mere being this second is
the universal unity which contains all
these moments is superseded within
itself it is the simple genius which in
the movement of life itself does not
exist for itself qua this simple
determination on the contrary in this
result life points to something other
than itself that is to consciousness for
which life exists as this unity or as
genus
after that long paragraph number 171 in
which Hegel brought together all these
different dimensions life and ultimately
brought them to the came whole now we're
gonna see a succession of you might say
one two short punches in these very
short paragraphs from 172 through
through 174 and he's going to introduce
or reintroduce a term that's going to be
very important for us now in connection
with life and that is consciousness so
how does he get there by the end of
section or paragraph 172 he says since
we started from the first immediate
unity so he's taking up what's been
going on in this section what's the
first immediate unity life or you know
you might say it can go even further
back to to self-consciousness except
that we're finding that
self-consciousness isn't really
immediate right because it's got this
mediated relation to itself of the self
in self-consciousness so we need
something else
it's got to be life the first immediate
unity the first immediate unity we
started at we went through the moments
of formation process to the unity of
both of these moments what are the the
two moments that is referring to these
moments of life as life and the living
thing or if you want to say the moment
of the living thing as opposing itself
to a consuming life and the further
moment of the overcoming the out fable
of that opposition by showing that that
life in its very supersession of the
living thing produces the living things
all of that is is what we've done so far
and what we get to through all of that
is now he says a universal unity so what
we've got going on it is the typical
Hegelian progression from an immediate
starting point through looking at the
complexities things start separating out
their relations to each other start
becoming clear and we
finally end up with some sort of unity
some sort of hole in which there is
organism in which there is complexity in
which there is structure so as he's
gonna say it contains all the previous
moments right this encompasses all of
this within itself as superseded and the
term there is alt South Cahawba no it is
not itself overcoming those moments or
superseding those moments those moments
haven't been superseded and are now part
of what this universal unity is so unity
in this this term here in height is not
really the same thing here as it is here
here it's a kind of create unity
it's a developed unity now he's going to
go on and he says this is very important
contrasted with that immediately entity
or that unity expressed is a mere being
just you know just something showing up
the second is the universal medium which
contains all these moments is superseded
within itself that means that it is the
simple genus or Gong a type a you know
this is a term that's used for types but
it's not it's not used just for types of
things altogether another translation of
this is sometimes species right so we
have a biological metaphor going on here
it's a simple genus which is the result
of this now what does that mean
a simple genus we're going to see this
spelled out a little bit more in the
next passages but when we're talking
about genus Azure species whether we're
talking in serve you know broad
Aristotelian terms or in more biological
terms you know where they're living
things what are we actually talking
about they're a determinate kind of
thing so can this really be a
determinate kind of thing well yes
because it can be life it has the Gotham
life as what's over here encompassing
all
this now Hagel says something really
interesting really important he says
that this this simple genius in the
movement of life itself
does not exist for itself as this simple
determination grasping what's going on
yeah is going as genus as type is not
something possible for life itself it's
possible for a certain kind of life or a
certain range or if we want to play
around that certain doctoring of life
says life points to something other than
itself what does that mean life points
to something other than itself
well the something other it is in this
case consciousness right so life leads
to consciousness consciousness comes out
of life well it's not just that it says
consciousness for which life exists as
this you know without consciousness life
just simply goes on and that's that once
we have consciousness there is something
that can say aha
there is a unity to this I can give it a
name I can think about it I can feel
about it
we're not necessarily at human
consciousness yet although that keep
that in mind because we're going to
shift to it very quickly but life is for
consciousness not consciousness simply
for life this is an important point
Haley is an idealist he does not think
that life you know I'll just exist by
itself and it's kind of absurd
meaninglessness processes going on and
then BOOM consciousness shows up on the
scene and then trying to figure out what
the hell am I supposed to do with all
this stuff and then gets more more
complex now Hegel thinks that by the
time that you can even start talking
about processes or something like that
consciousness is already on the scene
you're not going to get away from
consciousness
this other life however for
which the geniuses such exists and which
is genius on its own account that is
self-consciousness exists in the first
instance of sub 4 self-consciousness
only as this simple essence and has
itself as pure I four subject in the
course of its experience which we are
now to consider this abstract object
will enrich itself for the eye and
undergo the unfolding which we have seen
in the sphere of life
in paragraph 173 now we see self
consciousness not just consciousness but
self consciousness come back on the
scene in this very short passage he
talks about this other life right so we
have the other life and we have life as
such as like I put here as the fluid
medium as the process in which
individual and life's or square off
against each other as a super session
the collapse of those moments into each
other that we've already seen and he
talks about the genus as such the gong
that we've just talked about which is
this this whole realm of life existing
for another life now what is this other
life it is self consciousness and it is
self consciousness as he's going to
point out in a very important way by
being a genus sort of like the genus
over here I got zone for self itself and
I wanted to insist on on this you know
well somewhat clumsy elocution
why not just say it's a genus for itself
well because the way that hingle is
expressing it is for its very own self
for what it is in itself you might say
so the in itself in the for itself are
are connected together here conceptually
in a striking manner the other life is a
genus for it something with that what
that means is we actually have two
different genus is here although perhaps
this one is supposed to fit into this
one right you know as species does to
genus but they're also in opposition to
each other there's a lot going on in
this very short passage sometimes the
brevity shouldn't conceal for us as it
does in its form that there's a lot of
content being implicitly developed here
you know what's the real upshot of this
and what's going to give us the new
direction of movement for the next
full of paragraphs is that he talks
about this other life that is you know
self-consciousness aware of itself for
which this other you know this other
exists he says it exists only as this
simple essence and has itself as pure I
as object a pure subject a pure I think
or I can or I am here it doesn't yet
have determinacy self-consciousness has
this polarity going on within it that
we're going to see happen and in Hegel
over and over again there is on the one
hand as has been pointed out by many
philosophers before Hegel something that
insofar as we are human beings and we
are beings that take a position upon our
own process of thinking acting you know
often and very sophisticated ways like
writing philosophy books we can talk
about a pure I that that we all have in
common
we saw however already in the the very
first dialectic that we're looking at
with sense certainty that any sort of
pure I ends up you know slipping away
from me if I can say I I'm not the PRI
any more than you are I am this
determinate being so we want to figure
out how we're going to get that
deterministic back you know is the the
relationship of self-consciousness
merely one in which we have this pure i
something like the you know cartesian
coach ito as subject or other you know
things the rational mind of Augustine or
Anselm
the disembodied soul of Plato that's
that satisfying and we're going to see
satisfaction is very important as we go
through this so Hegel is going to insist
that self-consciousness
needs to go through a process of
experience where does pure eye is
actually going to be unfolded into
something more determinate and the whole
thing that we just studied with life is
such then is going to provide us where
the blueprint with the model he says
quite clearly here in the course of his
experience the abstract object will
enrich itself for the eye and undergo
the unfolding which we have seen in in
the sphere of life life is not the end
of the story for Hegel but it is
actually showing us one important
dimension of movement
the simple I is this genus or the simple
Universal for which the differences are
not difference is only by its being the
negative essence of the shaped
independent moments and
self-consciousness is the certain of
itself only by superseding this other
that presents itself to
self-consciousness as an independent
life self-consciousness is desire
certain of the nothingness of this other
it explicitly affirms that this
nothingness is for it the truth of the
other it destroys the independent object
and thereby gives itself the certainty
of itself as a true certainty a
certainty which has become explicit for
self-consciousness itself in an
objective manner
in paragraph 174 we're going to see the
beginning of this experience that we
just talked about in paragraph 173 as
needed to get us away from the pure or
simple eye and now we're going to see
how that actually develops this is a
very important and interesting turning
point for Hegel's viewpoint on
self-consciousness and how it must
necessarily develop now you know when
we're talking about Hegelian necessity
let's remember that we're not talking
about something like you know what many
people conceive of its pure logical
necessity totally extracted from
everything else which tends to give us
mainly tautologies you know and a few
other things which can be interesting
but not an awful lot of development what
we're talking about here is something
more along the lines of being able to
see retrospectively how things needed to
develop in this manner and so he GLE
here is making one of his very bold
claims that is perhaps debatable that
the relationship to the other as other
necessarily involves a kind of what we
might say antagonism so let's see how
this develops he talks about the simple
I the Gina's the simple universal and he
says these are the differences or not
difference is only by being the negative
essence of the shaped into independent
moments because that's that's all very
interesting stuff right there but not
the real core he says self-consciousness
is certain of itself only by superseding
the other that presents itself to
self-consciousness as an independent
life so this is where the real media's
self-consciousness
can only be certain of itself by somehow
some leading superseding transcending
however we want to put it I was able
this other this independent life there's
something outside of itself notice that
at this point we're not yet talking
necessarily about another self-conscious
life although that's where we're heading
so he says you know self-consciousness
is desire this is what it means to be
desire that desire wants to supersede
the other independent life how does it
supersede it it makes it no longer
independent it makes it for the stuff it
brings the other which is insofar as its
other something that is independent of
the self of the pure eye within the
ambit of it so he says certain of the
nothingness of this other now certain of
the nothingness how is it actually
certain of the nothing it's projecting
that how to help that's a you might say
an aggressive move desire is in part
designer for what is independent as
we're gonna see in the next paragraph
but it's also desire to annul its
independence to make it into a
nothingness into a nullity to consume it
this is what consumption really is so he
says it explicitly affirms this
nothingness is for it the truth of the
other so here it's revealed the truth of
the other which is nothingness the other
now why is the other nothing that's
because the self the self conscious and
that's the the the unity has in fact
imposed that upon the other so he says
it destroys the independent object and
gives itself now we've got truth and it
gives itself the certainty of itself as
true certainty this is the movement of
unselfconsciousness it is looking to
attain truth and certainty about itself
and the tragic you know condition that
it's in is that it can only do so in
relation to what is
on itself and how is it going to do that
well one way is to try to annul or to -
Nene late in the sorry in terms right or
to batter down and consume the other
in this satisfaction however experience
makes it aware that the object has its
own independence desire and the self
certainty obtained in its gratification
are conditioned by the object force all
certainty comes from superseding this
other in order that this super session
can take place there must be this other
thus self-consciousness by its negative
relation to the object is unable to
supersede it it is really because of
that relation that it produces the
object again and the desire as well it
is in fact something other than
self-consciousness that is the essence
of desire and through this experience
self-consciousness has itself realized
this truth but at the same time it is no
less absolutely for itself and it is so
only by superseding the object and it
must experience its satisfaction for it
is the truth an account of the
independence of the object therefore it
can achieve satisfaction only when the
object itself
affects the negation within itself and
it must carry out this negation of
itself in itself for it is in itself the
negative and must be for the other what
it is since the object is in its own
self negation and in being so is at the
same time independent it is
consciousness in the sphere of life
which is the object of desire negation
is present either in another that is in
desire or as a determinate Ness opposed
to other in different form or as the
inorganic universal nature of life but
this independent is universal
independent nature in which negation is
present is absolute negation is the
genus as such or the genus as
self-consciousness self-consciousness
achieves its satisfaction only in
another self-consciousness
after those three short but very
important paragraphs now in the longer
paragraph 175 we're going to play off of
those and there's a lot going on in this
passage we're going to have a transition
which is almost on the cusp of getting
us into another self-consciousness and
the Dewey attic relationship that's
going to run through almost the rest of
this entire self-consciousness session
but we got to get there so what we're
going to look at is what I've got here
is that sort of paradoxes of desire and
satisfaction that are going on that
Hegel is churning out land
he's already introduced this issue of
you know satisfaction means the you know
me the you know the the vacation or the
destruction whatever of the other so
that the the self can have not only
truth but also self certainty and I've
depicted that here right let's you know
sort of a diagram you know
self-consciousness it negates or
destroys its other so they you know it's
desire can be fulfilled
what is its desire for it's not just for
say food or drink or sacks or dominance
or anything like that it's so that it
can actually have self certainty so that
it can have a certitude a give insight
about itself and then it can be a true
one it can assure itself that at the
same time
heckles not saying that every
self-consciousness that's eating a
hamburger is necessarily doing that in
an explicit way but there that's part of
the process so he says in this
satisfaction here's where we get the
first paragraph experience remember the
the eye is supposed to experience what's
actually going on in its unfolding like
the tip of what it finds that the object
has its own independence it says desire
and the self certainty obtained in this
gratification are conditioned by the
object that's a problem the object here
is is the other right and the other is
is being a null but what's being a No
is supposed to also condition the sensor
that sense certainly the self certainty
that's available and as a result the
satisfaction self is being conditioned
by what is being destroyed so doesn't
that mean that the satisfaction itself
is being destroyed in the process he
says self certainty comes from
superseding the other in order that the
supersession can take place there must
be this other so like I put here
superseding the other you know engaging
in this sublation or al-haytham that's a
very aggressive one that's trying to
consume the other that's trying to
destroy the other in order that that
just the Seltzer the self-consciousness
can be there in relation to itself it
requires that the other be that the
other exists that the other not only be
at that moment but continue in some way
to exist so can it really destroy the
other not really because if it does all
bets are off
so he says self consciousness by it's
negative relation to the object is
therefore unable to supersede it
self-consciousness cannot supersede the
other the object that which is different
than itself it it has to try to
supersede it
that's what desire wants and at the same
time it can't quite pull it off if it
does manage to pull it off then you know
there's no object anymore and so what do
we get going on this is very interesting
you know realization of reproduction
this is a really key idea here there is
a temporal process of a reproduction
both of the object or the other and a
desire that's taking place this is
something by the way when we think about
you know handles larger impact you know
this this whole self consciousness
section has been one that is you know
probably drawn the most attention in the
20th and 21st century because of the
master slide
dialectic but it's also drawing a lot of
attention because of the fact that what
is going on is a repetition a
reproduction of both the object right
the object that's supposed to be
destroyed how do you reproduce an object
well you know you exhaust here's a great
example you exhaust one piece of chalk
or two pieces of chalk by turning them
into little nubs go and find yourself
another piece of chalk that's what I do
right because I have the same object in
mind which means that I'm reproducing
desire itself
why desire in Z is a negative relation
it doesn't have what it actually wants
it's not a pure positivity it is an
expression of what it means to be
conscious and to be self conscious
remember consciousness involves negation
that's a key to getting an idea all of
this means that insofar as we do
actually manage to annul the other we
got to go around looking for another
other right I eat my toast in the
morning tomorrow I'm gonna I want to eat
some more toast and it can't be the same
toast I'm sure to find myself another
piece of bread and toast it up so I can
put some other you know butter or jam or
jelly or I like tomatoes and radishes as
well you get the idea all right if we
consume the object or the other
we don't retain the satisfaction and we
have to reproduce it so he says it is
because of that relation it produces the
object again and the desire as well the
fact that we cannot actually consume
what it is that we are bent on consuming
so this has some very important
implications it is in fact something
other than self consciousness that is
the essence of desire self consciousness
is involved in the essence of desire
right because whose desire isn't its
self consciousness is desire well what
this means is that the
other is equally involved in the desire
the the other draws the desire it's not
as if self-consciousness as a pure
agency casting its desire around and
latching onto things and reeling them in
and eating them up or something like
that the other the object is drawing the
desire to it and conditioning it he says
through this experience
self-consciousness he has itself
realized this truth now we see that
truth is starting to fly over this way
it's not just something that that
self-consciousness possesses and can
keep to itself like a miser with its
hoard or his hoard or her heart that
that turning a miser into a thing
although ironically the dialectic of
being a miser is that you know being
obsessed with things so much that one
actually does kind of turn itself into a
thing
total siding out there so he goes and he
says at the same time it's no less
absolutely for itself that is
self-consciousness it's only by
superseding the object and must
experience its satisfaction for it is
the truth it's insisting on this I have
to experience satisfaction so I'm
encountering the independence of the
object that can attain satisfaction only
when something other than this wholes so
how what would allow the
self-consciousness to attain
satisfaction in the other who has to be
negated and yet can't be negated because
the other has to remain in place in
order for this to really work because
the other is conditioning the self
certainty or the satisfaction that's
happening well there is a possibility
there is a move that takes it out of
this but it's not a move that
self-consciousness can make it's a move
that the other has to make if the other
negates or produces negation or destroy
something or a sacrifice of something in
itself we
is hardly destroying itself then
self-consciousness can actually have the
satisfaction that it desires so you know
if I can get the object to do part of
the work you might say for doing this in
culinary terms what is cooking well this
is a prime example right think about
meat can you eat raw meat doesn't
getting some of it you know
steak tartare and sushi and stuff like
that but can you really sit around and
eat raw meat all day long
mmm not going to work out for you very
well certainly you're not going to eat
it and it's it's pure you know off the
animal sort of state so what do we do we
cook the meat we do something to it now
in that case we're actually you know
sort of pre digesting it before we're
digesting and our saliva by the way is
is part of the digestive process as well
our chewing our masticating all those
sorts of things now imagine that we get
the the meat to sort of cook itself
right to prepare itself for us there's a
Homer Simpson episode if I remember
right where the animal that's a pig I
think is like cutting off bits of itself
and serving it's a Homer
that's what self-consciousness is really
looking for to attain complete
satisfaction now notice in that cartoon
we have the animal doing something
that's very human-like all right so
that's going to play a role here he says
on account of the independence of the
object it can attain satisfaction only
when the object itself affects the
negation within itself and it must carry
out this negation of itself in itself
why because it is in itself the negative
and must be for the other this is the
other now in this case the self the
other is the other two the self it must
be for the other what it is now what
does that mean here very important
implication since the object is in its
own self negation and in beating so it
is they at the same time in
what does that mean that means that the
object itself is consciousness right the
other is consciousness self
consciousness doesn't just want to
consume you know trees blow things off
eat things you know change the landscape
it wants another consciousness it's
desiring something that has negativity
of its own to deploy so he says in the
in the sphere of life which is the
object of desire negation is present
either in another that is in desire or
as a determinant as opposed to another
independent different form as the
inorganic universal nature of life we
saw this before right this other over
here can be that that life is in general
that we consume and all that were
already past that now though so negation
is present in another which is also
desire and which is actually going to be
desire related to the desire of the self
acting on the other you've seen all
things are starting to play out here
right so he says this Universal
independent nature in which negation is
president is the absolute negation is
the genus as such right or
self-consciousness so where does
self-consciousness attain its
satisfaction only in another
self-consciousness something else which
is also able to desire something else
which then in return can desire towards
self-consciousness
you